back in the old day when I was starting
off on YouTube horror was the only thing
I would play I would play horror every
single day now the horror genre back
then was actually a dying genre although
the big title games like Silent Hill
resident evil fear condemned these
really staple of the John Rowe horror
titles had all turning to action games
instead of horror games it was really
sad to see and for me who was trying to
make a living I had to find all these
horror games but they were so few and
indie games is really what brought back
the horror genre amnesia especially but
there were a few others at the time and
I remember I could literally count all
of them on my hands like it was Bond
Chun Doong ghost Ione X mortis this
[ __ ] point and click game which guys
remember that game Nosferatu I don't
even think that was an indie game
nowadays the amount of horror games is
what hundreds thousands I remember
someone suggested Slender to me five
years ago and then literally searched
top I'm like whoa this this game looks
amazing I can't wait to play it has
anyone else played it and I looked and
there was not a single video of it and
I'm like holy [ __ ] I gotta play this
right now and I did and it went so
[ __ ] viral and now you such slender
in YouTube then there's five million
results and there was one car game that
I could just not get ahold of because it
was Korean so to play it yet to
illegally download wish I would never do
I would never do that which is why I
never played it god dammit because I am
with the law and it's called white day
but now it's out on Steam and I thought
for good old times sake let's play this
old last Korean horror game that now has
been ported to Steam
I'm watching a cry play this as well as
I know the interest sequence
[Music]
we're gonna get some skirt action I
always wonder what the the actual story
was
[Music]
green grass the brightly shining Sun and
her
[Music]
you
I mean it looks pretty good I like the
art style I think they did a good job
it's this extremely uninteresting what
is this I don't take my photos a paper
honey
hey you like a photo I can take thought
of you
I guess me I gotta go as history a story
right there
all right unless unless everyone dies
they like that's the same [ __ ] exact
tree so young hands junior homeroom she
was there wow what a story mark there we
are
just play the [ __ ] you run by pressing
space okay I should go to junior
homeroom okay oh my god oh my god just
let me [ __ ] play why do I run with
spacebar who the [ __ ] what's running on
spacebar I need a key
oh yeah I remember I think you get the
flashlight in here oh yeah in Korea s
this weird ass [ __ ] toilet things
that I'm sitting in LLL get out what the
[ __ ] that's disgusting that's not how
you hide man this is not it come on
flashlight I know you're here somewhere
I remember five years ago
come on flashlight there's something I
need to do here it's too dark okay
all right fine do you see now but a tip
of a pen oh wow oh there it is there's
window Oh cigarettes
I remember your cigarettes that's right
who put cigarettes in a school disgust
hey you look pretty good okay let's
check it
oh yeah there's two bathrooms okay all
right cool maybe there's maybe there's
something here huh where's my [ __ ]
flashlight surprise surprise surprise
really nothing the storage locker what's
happening
Oh what have we got another pen why the
[ __ ] do I need a pen my god what was
that sound I am so scared if what wow
that's fun what was saying my god this
game is terrifying
I've never been this scared in my lap oh
my god there's someone else at school
this is the scariest game I've rolled
time
yo what a purchase I have your diary oh
I get to choose dialogue and [ __ ] uh
sorry
I bet this changes the whole game
really I wonder how big is your kids I'm
glad that you're here you are going to
help me out
god dammit
just something follow me fine but I
won't like it
I will definitely like it I want to his
smash that like you showed up a guy like
me you hear that I'm - I'm - boy you
mean giant nothingness I got shoes and
buttons oh my god she's yes I told you I
told you sniffing the urinal why worried
I want something weird she's totally
flirting with me okay so we need to get
there if you look around the school
you'll be able to shut the [ __ ] up
I got you fam there said toolbox here I
remember that she did how where's the
toolbox huh
the door okay where's the toolbox there
you are and I remember they explained it
you could grab this Hey
shut up shut up all right which one is
calling this one well I guess I missed a
call mr. ladder you're coming with me
buddy the [ __ ] up planes going pretty
good so far
memories memories memories they never
stop where the brush go there you are
okay
all right put let it down here and then
I walk up ladder here and then I use the
bus but cutter box cutter as you can see
here by this animation I am cutting it
oh wow that's how it fell off because I
cut the glue and here I go sayonara
brush shutter see you later don't look
at my ass she's definitely looking at my
ass
well what's happening oh my god yes I
remember oh it's janitor it's the
janitor everybody the crazy janitor
that's it schools janitor just like
every school has a janitor that beats
people up so does this school Korea not
even once
I'm sure that wouldn't have no
consequences whatsoever for me I'm
guessing we can't go there because I'm
hot steam which old school has okay
these are bad up okay puzzles oh my god
it's a puzzle everybody think I can
solve it
let's see her turning the valve we will
turn off the seam I must be some sort of
genius okay we only did it to one of
them that's fine we'll find the other
one my god that was extremely difficult
task but I was able to accomplish it
[Music]
thank thank God I have such pure Swedish
intellection yes intellection now I
don't know the only reason I know and to
go here it's because we solve the puzzle
flashlight would be pretty good oh my
god it's a box ah
oh what the there is a demon box oh my
god yes
yes this Bell doesn't stop get used to
this [ __ ] Bell sound because he does
not [ __ ] stop oh my god oh great
you can't see anything it's too dark
how about this giant [ __ ] demons
thing is that not letting it up for you
oh god okay one two three four five
what is this Bioshock which ones need to
be connected then one
oh I see
it isn't transfer
well it's impossible for all of them to
be connected oh my god this is so
annoying
it doesn't okay so I can read this one
it can be shut down temporarily by
connecting the third and the fourth
god damn it oh I can't see anything
except this document okay the three and
four
well I solved it by accident Jesus
Christ what a great puzzle
shut up box hell yeah it just flew out
man he just it just came right at me man
it's on my phone man I just turn off the
alarm
what a great security system turn off
the alarm
the thing just go along hey we got the
homeroom key excellent now we can open
doors nobody likes an unshielded man
nobody likes a salty main building first
central hallway okay where is that you
you pondering about life over there or
what's happening yeah some deep thoughts
I'll let I'll leave you to it I'll leave
you to it don't worry buddy I'm just
gonna I'm just gonna go [ __ ] if I know I
guess here this place is creepy I don't
like it
okay let's go why am I still here
why am I here Oh God
that can't begin oh [ __ ] it's the
janitor it's the janitor but he has a
limp man I remember being chased by this
[ __ ] janitor what oh you broke the
game
I don't care about you all right let's
head on out oh my god
there's just the scariest enemy I have
ever seen [ __ ] him surrounded why would
you hurt me
while he's away I gave you everything I
gave you seven years of my life
he's whistled he's got a whistle
it's okay I got an old trick up my
sleeve lighter lighter [ __ ] [ __ ]
ladder oh god I did I not save oh god I
don't think I saved okay I remember now
you you pressed you put the demon symbol
in the demon symbol hole which as you do
as a demon simple man
of course of course that's how you do it
all right let's go upstairs knock the
janitor main that bald son of a [ __ ]
okay we're up here now this is when the
game gets a little confusing I remember
can we investigate all the clocks in
this game yes please do you know how
much I love clocks
dammit clock [ __ ] you [ __ ] you too plain
[ __ ] all of you
what what's making that sound shut up
everyone shut up okay we got another pin
[Music]
I'm not scared okay I'm not scared I'm
not scared okay what your balls son of a
[ __ ] goddamn goddamn oh no oh I got a I
gotta use my super moon hide oh we got a
document I thought you had a limp man
what
I'm dead I'm [ __ ] dead are you happy
Oh No
how can he run forever hide hide hide
hide na hai hai hai today
yeah your people [ __ ] on me ah what the
[ __ ] this game is impossible it's
impossible to run away from the janitor
he has a limp he has a limp how is this
not even [ __ ] serious how does this
[ __ ] Oh God he's coming
[Music]
who blows a whistle
oh my god oh my god oh he's looking for
a how does he not see me just stand real
still
just stand really still and they tricked
me hey pumpkin faked me it looked like
he was leaving and then he beat the [ __ ]
out of me
[ __ ] this game my god I was a scariet
and love letter as a scariest moment of
my life
god damn [ __ ] the janitor man [ __ ] the
janitor man oh I swear to God is he
gonna cook
oh my god what is your problem
I am innocent
oh look I found the car three one two
six excuse me don't kill me
what did I say what an idiot
here we go finally some progress okay
shut up game three one two six I pressed
it wrong
three one one two
they're ready wow we got the key and a
small key as well oh my god I am so
spooked this is it
come on genius god damn it
[ __ ] you janitor janitor I bet you're
not even a real janitor yeah getting
janitor you fake-ass [ __ ] janitor
there's never anything in these never oh
this better be the [ __ ] exit
Oh
that's not the exit
[Music]
excuse me lady from the Grunch movie I
think I took the wrong turn oh well that
was great what in him what a nice
experience oh she left her school time
what an idiot
oh we can go in here now what the [ __ ]
was she doing with that tree huh
what that [ __ ] was she doing with that
tree Wow things are so much more
pleasant here now swear to [ __ ] god
if I run into the [ __ ] janitor
they're big hi I know you're seeing me
well you need to learn proper grammar go
back to school
ah hell yeah this is where the hentai
begins
you dropped something
but you dropped something
all right well I'm just gonna go okay
what a perfect time to end this episode
a nice little blast from the past
finally now I've played them all
officially I played them [ __ ] Oh was
it worth it absolutely not
have we learned anything [ __ ] no anyway
I hope you enjoyed this episode I had a
lot of fun playing it was fun maybe like
if you enjoyed as well
family squad Jiu Jitsu and I'm out